[Music]
it's our first look at the friends
reunion special which debuts
thursday may 27th on hbo max
i'm really excited it's not much but
check out the cast walking together from
behind
seemingly heading to set the cast is
incredibly grateful
and want to give back you know by doing
this special
the network also released a star-studded
list of special guests that will be
featured
well that i can believe they include
david beckham justin bieber mindy kaling
cindy crawford james corden lady gaga
and bts very exciting
i know former friends guest stars reese
witherspoon
and tom selleck will also make
appearances oh my god richard
monica chandler hey hey hey
that's the best one it's clear the cast
is excited for this reunion courtney cox
recently shared
this video to instagram playing a cover
of the friends theme song
yeah courtney shared that just after the
cast finished taping the reunion special
and her fellow friends co-star lisa
kudrow told et
this last year i can't wait for it to
happen i mean the six of us haven't been
in a room together in front of people in
25 years and only once
a few years ago just privately for
dinner so and we had a great time
so i can only imagine it's going to be
fun i mean it'll be really fun